bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france cet après midi quelle
influence la cedeao peut-elle avoir sur
la situation en valais sur les
militaires désormais aux manettes selon
vous c'est toujours bien que le sida ou
puisse et j'ai essayé de gérer les
conflits qui a fait la sous région mais
la question centrale c'est de savoir
quelle est la légitimité de
l'institution h
ce régional lorsqu'on voit la façon dont
elle traite les questions liées au
troisième mandat et surtout les
précédents les lié à la mort distribuer
dont le président du cade donc au niveau
de la légitimité on voit mal quel
argument qu'on peut fournir colonel
keïta donc la question n'est pas de
savoir si la cedeao doit s'impliquer hui
elle doit le faire mais elles at elle
vraiment la légitimité lorsqu'on sait
que l'institution elle même depuis
quelques années souffre d'une profonde
crise de légitimité et nous sommes aussi
face à une cedeao qui a du mal à
concevoir une transition authentique et
politique qui irait dans le sens d'une
refondation de l'état malien en tout cas
de sorte à le faire d'un état capable de
relever les défis de justice et
d'égalité politique parce que le son
dans une conception de la transition qui
fait des élections présidentielles
l'objectif de la transition et depuis
d'ailleurs le coup d'état de boot
on voit que nous sommes dans une rue une
vision où on s'intéresse simplement à ce
que les civils retourne au pouvoir alors
que la transition n'est pas simplement
lié à une question électorale
elle a aussi dit aux causes qui
conduisent ajustements à l'effondrement
des états en afrique est principalement
roumanie donc il ya là quelque part une
déception de voir que la cedeao à la
fois sous légitimité politique mais
aussi n'a pas une conception authentique
de la transition politique
comment est-ce que vous interprétez
l'invitation du colonel toute façon on
ne peut pas penser le mali penser avec
aïssi pas les mots du mali sans la junte
d'un responsable actuel de la junte donc
l'invitation va dans le sens de
l'apaisement le montrer que 7,7
c'est un homme qui participe de la
situation et dont la collaboration
serait nécessaire pour trouver une
solution à la crise malienne mais je
pense aussi que c'est une façon pour
dire que
peut-être qu'il ne serait pas possible
de reconduire le reconduire l'ex
président de la transition
donc il ya là quelque part un pas vers
la travers le responsable de la junte
qui pourrait peut-être les inciter à à
l'achat un peu le morceau ou en tout cas
ne pas jouer dur dans les futures
négociations mer au delà de l'invitation
du colonel guetta ce qu'il faut voir
aussi c'est que le mali le futur le
devenir politique du mali ne pas être
sans l'implication de l'armée malienne
qui a fait justement de la politisation
de l'institution militaire
une pratique courante et même normale
dans quelque part la cbao elle-même doit
s'inscrire dans une perspective où on le
ne pense pas simplement à une transition
qui verra le retour des civils au
pouvoir
mais un transition qui obligea à ce que
les maliens comme collectivité comme
nation interrogent leur devenir
politique et social parce que le
problème ce n'est pas que simplement
civile viennent au pouvoir
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans les années
90 on le voit aujourd'hui d'ailleurs la
majorité des états de l'afrique de
l'ouest vous sont sont présidées par des
civils où l'armée assure la légitimité
politique is on assiste aujourd'hui à
une souveraineté du canon qui a pris la
place la souveraineté populaire
donc ce n'est pas simplement lucas du
mali le mali n'est que le miroir d'une
afrique en décadence politique d'une
afrique qui se cherche dans les voix de
la démocratie
on a entendu les propos d' emmanuel
macron une forme de pression avec quels
effets attendus sur le pouvoir
au mali la france joue la carte de la
menace déjà dit c'est que c'est un
argument qui pèse ce que c'est un
argument sénart du maquis qui pourrait
peser mais il faut encore ils foutent
ils il faut en fait il faut voir dans
lequel quel sens le colonel keïta et et
ses amis peuvent recevoir cet argument
n'a évidemment que le président macron
peu jeu la stabilité
mais une fois encore le précédent
tchadien joue en sa défaveur
et même les faveurs de l'union africaine
et de la cedeao parce que bien que la
circonstance ne soit pas la même au
tchad et au mali on voit quand même que
la france accompagné mais officiellement
il est ouvertement il sans complexe la
prise du pouvoir au tchad par la junte
militaire on a beau dire
abou convoqué la vertu de l'armée
tchadienne et surtout le contexte où sir
ou kde niveau sous régional avec
justement le terrorisme plus de ma
question ça ils viennent il reste que
c'est quand même une entorse aux
principes démocratiques et surtout un
dévoiement des outils de la démocratie
que ce soit au tchad ou au mali donc
là-dessus l'argument sécuritaire n'a pas
un argument de poids bien sic on peut le
le prétexte est pour faire pression
diplomatique sur la junte au mali mais
cet argument là ne en fait que
participer un avantage à délégitimer la
la diplomatie française et les états de
l'afrique de l'ouest
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui la carte de
la stabilité ne doit pas marginaliser
justement les perspectives de la
démocratie en afrique
il faut ce qu'il faut voir que les
transitions ne sont pas réellement
penser il faut éviter d'inscrits le
transition simplement dans une logique
électoraliste
il faut essayer de dossi de ne pas faire
des transitions une espèce de pause qui
consisterait à reconduire plus tard le
même la prob a fait le problème une fois
encore ça n'est pas le pouvoir civil
c'est la façon dont en afrique de
manière générale d'ailleurs je m'étonne
de voir que le président m'a candy qui
ne sera pas au coût très en fait des
régimes qui manque de légitimité
démocratique lorsqu'on sait qu'un
afrique de manière générale tous les
régimes souffre d'une légitimité
démocratique à commencer par la côte
d'ivoire et la guinée d'alpha condé donc
ce n'est pas ça la question c'est
comment aujourd'hui les états africains
comme collectivité peut se réapproprier
leur destin et penser le devenir
politique au delà même de la france et
de l'implication du quai d'orsay
c'est aux africains aujourd'hui
d'interroger leur capacité collective à
vivre ensemble de se doter
d'institutions politiques et sociales
qui puisse essayer de les distribuer le
pouvoir à ce que l'institution militaire
gère ses prérogatives dans
l'indépendance de l'institution aussi du
pouvoir exécutif
et depuis les indépendances nous sommes
en face aujourd'hui d'un système
prétoriens d'un système politique où
partout d'ailleurs
l'armée assure la légitimité du pouvoir
politique c'est ça aussi que la
transition au mali doit pouvoir penser
si on veut sortir la malien de la crise
merci beaucoup pour votre regard amado
john barry je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de philosophie je rappelle
aussi le titre de votre ouvrage essai
sur la fondation politique de la guinée
c'est aux éditions l'harmattan